vamos a usar las ecuaciones que acabamos
de inferir para resolver el problema que
definimos en el vídeo anterior
escribamos de nuevo los datos del
problema tenemos la diferencia en
distancia que era igual a 500 metros o
lo que es lo mismo la altura de nuestro
precipicio y recuerden que es menos
porque estamos midiendo lo hacia abajo
así que este menos nos indica la
dirección hacia dónde va este
desplazamiento
tenemos nuestra monedita que en esta
ocasión la lanzamos hacia arriba con una
velocidad inicial de 30 metros por
segundo esto es positivo porque estamos
lanzando la moneda hacia arriba y arriba
se representa con el símbolo positivo la
dirección hacia abajo se representa con
un signo negativo tenemos la aceleración
de la gravedad que para facilitarnos los
cálculos la redondeamos a menos 10
metros por segundo al cuadrado
nuevamente es menos porque la dirección
de la gravedad es hacia abajo y
recordemos que la aceleración real de la
gravedad es de menos 9.8 metros por
segundo al cuadrado pero la redondeamos
a 10 para facilitar nuestros cálculos
ahora vamos a escribir la fórmula que
encontramos en el vídeo anterior
velocidad final al cuadrado es igual a
la velocidad inicial al cuadrado más dos
veces la aceleración por el tiempo
y vamos a usar la otra fórmula voy a
escribirla en otro color
vemos que la diferencia en distancia es
igual a la velocidad inicial
por el tiempo
más la aceleración por el tiempo al
cuadrado todo esto entre dos esta es la
fórmula con la que terminamos el vídeo
anterior sustituimos las variables con
los datos que tenemos aquí la diferencia
en distancia es menos 500 metros y esto
es igual a la velocidad inicial que
indicamos aquí arriba de 30 metros por
segundo
y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por el
tiempo más la aceleración que definimos
es de menos 10 metros por segundo al
cuadrado
por el tiempo al cuadrado todo esto
entre dos ahora vamos a simplificar esto
es igual a treinta metros por segundo
por el tiempo - ya que aquí tengo un -10
entre dos me va a quedar un menos cinco
metros por segundo al cuadrado
por el tiempo al cuadrado y ahorita para
seguir simplificando voy a hacer de
momento a un lado las unidades no las
voy a tomar en cuenta para no complicar
demasiado la escritura de esta ecuación
de manera que me va a quedar sin las
unidades menos 500 igual a 30 por t
menos 5 por t al cuadrado y si ustedes
han tomado ya clases de álgebra y si no
lo han hecho pueden consultar la serie
de vídeos que tenemos al respecto
ustedes ya sabrán cómo resolver estas
ecuaciones cuadráticas de todas maneras
si no se acuerdan cómo hacerlo no se
preocupen aquí vamos a resolverlo paso a
paso comencemos poniendo todos los
términos del lado izquierdo de esta
ecuación y los vamos a acomodar de
manera que el término cuadrática más
grande que es 5 t cuadrada y es 5
positivo porque al pasarlo del otro lado
de la igualdad cambio de signo es el
término que va a quedar más a la
izquierda después le sigue menos 30 te
cambió el signo porque lo pasamos de un
lado de la igualdad al otro lado
nos queda el menos 500 este si no cambio
de signo porque no se ha movido de su
lado de la igualdad todo esto va a ser
igual a cero podemos dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre 5 para simplificar
aún más los términos 55 me queda uno por
t al cuadrado que quédate cuadrada menos
30 entre 5 es menos seis menos seis por
t y menos 500 entre 5 nos va a quedar
igual a menos 100 y 0 entre 5 pues nos
va a quedar igual hacer para aquellos de
ustedes que necesiten un recordatorio de
cómo resolver estas ecuaciones
cuadráticas vamos a escribir las
fórmulas necesarias aquí
usando otro color en este caso el
elemento que nos interesa el tiempo
puede tener dos valores que dan solución
a esta ecuación que va a ser igual a
menos b más menos la raíz cuadrada de b
cuadrada menos 4 por a por c
y todo esto entre dos por a estas
variables a b y c representan los
coeficientes de los términos de esta
ecuación cuadrática a es el coeficiente
que acompaña al término cuadrática más
grande en este caso este cuadrada y el
coeficiente que lo acompaña es un 1 por
lo que a es igual a 1 esta vez es el
coeficiente que acompaña al siguiente
término que en este caso esté por lo que
ve es igual a menos 6 finalmente se
representa el coeficiente del término
constante en nuestra ecuación es el
menos 100 que es igual a menos 100 ahora
vamos a sustituir los valores de estos
coeficientes en la ecuación que acabo de
escribir nos va a quedar que t es igual
a menos ver pero aquí b es menos 6
más menos la raíz cuadrada de be
cuadrada quedamos que ves menos 6 menos
6 al cuadrado menos 4 por a pero a es 1
x se dice que damos que es menos 100
vamos a tener la raíz cuadrada de todo
esto y todo esto de acá vas a dividido
entre dos por a
recordamos que es igual a 1 por lo que
va a estar dividido entre dos vamos a
simplificar esto
el tiempo es igual menos por menos es
más
queda 6 positivo más menos raíz cuadrada
menos 6 al cuadrado menos 6 por menos 6
es igual a 36
menos cuatro por uno por menos 100 menos
por menos es más nos va a quedar que es
más 400
y todo esto entre dos sigamos
simplificando seis más menos raíz
cuadrada 36 más 400 es 436 y esto no va
a ser una raíz exacta todo esto entre
dos vamos a sacar la calculadora para
encontrar el valor de esta raíz cuadrada
la raíz cuadrada de 436 es igual a 20.88
lo escribimos aproximadamente igual a 6
más menos 20.8
aunque podemos redondear lo a 20.9 ya
que era 20.88 20.9
entre 2 y ahora podemos escribir que el
tiempo es igual a 6 + menos
20.9
entre 2 en el tiempo es aproximadamente
igual a esto imaginemos que tomamos aquí
el 6 y lo restamos al 20.9 si estamos
hablando de tiempo pues no podemos
hablar de un tiempo negativo así que
esto 6 - 20.9 nos quedaría un valor
negativo con esto podemos descartar esta
solución y elegir 6 + 20.9 entre 2 con
esto si tenemos un valor positivo para
el tiempo lo cual tiene lógica 26.9
entre 2
sacamos la calculadora de nuevo y
dividimos 26.9 entre 2
y nos va a dar 13.45 por lo que el
tiempo va a ser igual a aproximadamente
a 13.45 segundos aquí ya estoy
incorporando de nuevo las unidades
ustedes recordarán que las había quitado
para facilitarnos el trabajar con la
ecuación si ustedes quieren verificar
que estas unidades son las correctas los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y hagan
todos estos cálculos incluyendo las
unidades para que vean que quedan estas
unidades
este resultado es interesante este de
13.45 segundos si ustedes recuerdan hace
más o menos tres o cuatro vídeos atrás
cuando vimos este problema si dejábamos
caer la moneda simplemente soltando la
desde lo alto del acantilado en ese
problema yo les di el tiempo que era de
10 segundos para que la moneda llegara
al suelo y así encontramos que el
precipicio tenía una altura de 500
metros
si ustedes están en lo alto de un
edificio que mide 500 metros y dejarán
caer algo pequeño como una moneda que es
tan pequeña que casi no tiene
resistencia al aire le tomaría a 10
segundos llegar al suelo pero si lanzan
la moneda hacia arriba con una velocidad
de 30 metros por segundo le tomara 13.45
segundos llegar al suelo casi 3.5
segundos para que quede más claro esto
voy a dibujar a ambos precipicios
en este primer caso teníamos la moneda y
simplemente la dejábamos caer
en el segundo problema teníamos también
el mismo precipicio
pero la moneda en lugar de dejarla caer
la lanzamos hacia arriba y después
obviamente la fuerza de gravedad la va a
jalar hacia abajo
en el primer caso encontramos que la
distancia del precipicio era de 500
metros
y el tiempo que tardaba en caer esta
manera era de 10 segundos en el segundo
caso vemos que la distancia que recorre
esta moneda cuando primero la lanzamos
hacia arriba va a ser mayor a 500 metros
y es lógico que se tarde más tiempo
recorriendo una distancia mayor por eso
es que el tiempo nos quedó más grande
que en el primer caso fue de 13.45
segundos si este número hubiera sido
menor ustedes tendrían que haber
revisado sus operaciones pues no es
lógico que tome menos tiempo para la
moneda llegar al suelo si lo lance hacia
arriba y tiene más distancia que
recorrer espero que con esto quede más
claro los conceptos ahora ustedes tienen
en su arsenal todas las fórmulas y
espero la comprensión necesaria para
resolver los problemas de movimiento de
proyectiles en los siguientes vídeos
resolveremos varios problemas para que
queden bien claros estos conceptos y
después
expandiremos estos problemas para
cómo resolverlos cuando se tienen más
dimensiones más de dos dimensiones y
diferentes ángulos para esto les
recomiendo que repasen sus conocimientos
de trigonometría nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo